[Music]
right all of you welcome to ramsay
around the world uh i am in stunning
croatia it's been the most magical week
on earth and i've got to cook with one
of the most talented chefs croatia has
ever produced david sokol we have been
all over the shop
diving
hunting and found some of the most
exquisite ingredients i'm going to do a
fast track seafood stew but a stew that
doesn't take six or seven hours this is
not like your marseilles
this is a fast track stew with stuff
that i've found literally first time
this morning quick over ingredients
beautiful little little neck clams
cuttlefish longwasting leftover potatoes
some beautiful little tomatoes leeks
onions garlic and some wild thyme and
some beautiful forage herbs taken
literally from just around the corner on
that bank there first off i'm going to
start the base
every base
needs those vegetables and the nice
thing about this stew is that
it doesn't need to be
over finessed so it's a rustic
charming
stew but
one
has literally done in 10 minutes slice
the onions not too thin okay i'm cooking
them in a cast iron pan
so if you start slicing them thinly
they're going to burn just sort of about
three millimeters thick
from there
get your garlic
from there on
so
five nice cloves of garlic look at that
garlic beautiful
now
i want to use the
the whites
of these leeks they're baby leeks so
it's almost like a large spring onion
and the top parts i sort of tend to use
for a stock
or braise but these
bases on the leeks cook so quickly
now from there
bring that all together
over
and we'll start sweating that off
olive oil pan
let's go
now
into that cast iron in goes the olive
oil beautiful
be generous that olive oil this country
produces some of the best olive oil
anywhere in the world
vegetables in
beautiful that looks majestic right
there
sweat that down
nicely seasoned
beautiful and i really want this pepper
sort of quite open so i want large
chunks of pepper
they help to sort of
bring that little touch of heat to those
vegetables beautiful once i've started
sweating that off a little touch more
olive oil in there because this is
almost like a sort of
almost like a minestrone
style seafood base
keep it nice and flat on the bottom and
what that does now it starts to
caramelize all the vegetables and they
get all sticky
and delicious
i'm gonna pull that to the side
and then
sit my tomatoes in there
now
these beautiful dark red tomatoes i want
them to blister okay
and so
look at that pan now they just sort of
sit there
and blister beautifully cuttlefish
score season oil
sear
once i've got the color on there
turn these over
beautiful
and what it's doing now
is starting to open that shellfish
cuttlefish goes in
there
beautiful
get some color on there
20 seconds each side
beautiful
and then the white wine
but i want the lid on immediately white
wine in
and then bring it up to the boil
lid
on
so good vegetable sweaty down tomatoes
starting to burst
all that flavor's in there
i'm gonna take
my cuttlefish out
that sits on there they've started to
open
so look
at that beautiful
they go into the stew now
all that beautiful flavor and of course
like all shellfish if it doesn't open
throw it away look at that and that's
what that flavor
cooks within now
in she goes
cuttlefish
capers
olives parsley
potatoes that's beautiful right there's
a delicious potato cuttlefish salad with
capers
take your tomato
sauce
put that in
and mix now
look at that
beautiful
now leave that
to cook
for about three and a half to four
minutes
lid back on
now
once that's cooked down
look at the density of that
we take that over
to the table very carefully
and this is where the stew goes up a
level
your cuddle fish olives capers potatoes
go in at the last moment
okay
now i'm gonna gently
mix that over and look at that
mix that in
and the secret putting that cuttlefish
at the end is that we're not
gonna turn it into a rubbery
overcooked cuttlefish
a really nice delicious
seafood chew
and now
to serve
beautiful
god the colors are amazing
and the smell
is even better beautiful clams oh my
goodness i always like to put these bits
together at the end
and i sit that on top
just like that
just like that beautiful lady on that
spiral over there and then finally
lemon zest
finally
and then
this
liquid gold this beautiful glistening
incredible cold pressed extra virgin
olive oil
and that for me
is a perfect way
of doing
a delicious seafood stew
ala croatia
beautiful
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus
[Music]
you